this is the dilapidated temple nestled
within the escena outskirts you will be
coming here a lot to invest in your
character because there are more
resource systems in Circulo than ever
before let's break it down so that
you're ready on day one this is the
sculptor your savior after your arm is
severed and when it comes to your
prosthetic arm he's your guy if you find
a new attachment out in the world come
here to get it fitted and then you can
choose three attachments to equip in
your inventory screen and this allows
you to quick swap between them out in
the world and after defeating yo boo the
demon you'll acquire the mechanical
barrel which unlocks an upgrade path for
every single prosthetic tool you own and
with crafting materials like gunpowder
or scrap metal you can improve these
weapons in really interesting ways this
is a pre-release video so I don't know
them all but I do know this is long
spark an upgraded firecracker that
compounds gunpowder for a longer blue
there's gouging shuriken which allows
your shooter guns to hit multiple times
after they land and it seems you can
even imbue your weapons with elements
like this purple stuff and fire as well
there are a lot of upgrade paths in
secular and luckily for you there's a
guy in the hub world who is more than
happy to help you test them and maybe
one day they'll even kill him there are
three training options here for now
anyway there's attack step dodge and
deflect deflect is by far the most
important thing you can do in secular
make sure if you're a sauce player to
kick yourself every time you dodge when
you really should have been deflecting
it's really hard to overcome that muscle
memory and deflect is so good because in
addition to avoiding damage you actually
deal posture damage to your enemy if you
time your block correctly and you can
actually deplete even more posture if
you successfully deflect multiple
attacks in a row fill an enemy's posture
bar completely and you'll be rewarded
with a deathblow time your block
incorrectly and you actually won't take
damage but you will eventually be
knocked off balance which requires you
to spam block or dodge to get your
posture back
attacking is really important for you as
well because some enemies have
incredible posture they have these
defenses that you feel like you can't
get past unless you deal health damage
because then they'll start to take more
posture damage as they weaken the way
you deal health damage often is two-step
dodge away from an attack and then
counter with your own attack when
they're not blocking and if you're met
with this symbol that means an attack is
perilous and it means it's not easily
blocked jump or dash away from it
depending on the attack you have three
buttons for avoiding damage now and you
need to think pretty critically about
when you're using them correctly and
when you're using them incorrectly
because no matter how much you upgrade
your character and there are a lot of
ways to upgrade your character but no
matter how many times you do this you'll
just keep on dying if your fundamental
combat skills aren't good enough killing
enemies will also net you gold and
experience resources that will be halved
upon death unless you receive unseen aid
unseen aid is an rng effect that reduces
how much you lose upon death and you can
see that percentage chance in your
checkpoint menu here but be warned
because the more you die in sekito the
more the people around you will get a
disease called dragon rot this rot
essence screen will pop up for each
character and the more that get infected
the less likely you are to receive this
unseen aid but there's good news because
you can cure it later in the game Emma
will ask you to go and get a blood
sample from someone who has wrought
essence and once you have that blood
sample she'll hand you with dragon's
blood droplets and a recovery charm
which when you use them both together at
the Buddha statue they allow you to cure
the dragon drop of the victim whose
blood you acquired this grants you favor
with the gods once more and increases
your chance of receiving unseen aid
again will give dragon drop the
attention it deserves in this story
video coming soon so subscribe if you
haven't already anyway once you accrue
enough experience whether
from not dying or from receiving unseen
aid you'll have a few points to invest
in your characters own skill trees these
are accessible at the Buddha statues but
only when you've unlocked that skill
tree with an esoteric text the first
esoteric text unlocks the shinobi skill
tree and I think it's given to you by
the sculptor after you visit the Hirata
estates because there you remember the
shinobi you once were the shinobi tree
unlocks combat arts which are used by
pressing l1 and r1 at the same time this
one is called whirlwind strike which can
let you cleave down multiple enemies in
addition to this of course there are
also passive abilities things like
decreasing your presence so your stealth
gets stronger stuff like that and once
you reach the end there's actually a
final powerful combat ability that
unlocks the one at the end of the
shinobi skill tree which I grinded out
is called shadow rush it's this long
powerful thrust that uses an impaled
opponent as a platform to vault into the
skies sounds awesome I didn't get time
to try it though I speculate that every
skill tree ends in a powerful combat art
like this I think it's something to help
you define your playstyle and reward you
for investing in a skill tree and
something that represents the skill tree
you've chosen the second skill tree is
the prosthetic skill tree and this
unlocks as soon as you craft three
prosthetic weapons the first prosthetic
is in the escena outskirts and there are
two more in the errata estates we used
to think the third skill tree was going
to be called samurai but turns out it's
called the escena skill tree and it
still focuses on sword combat and
posture unlocking combat arts like
ichimonji a powerful overhead slice that
restores your posture as you step in to
attack I reckon there's going to be more
skill trees that you can unlock or at
least they're probably going to add more
with TLC later down the line experience
is also more interesting than you'd
expect because you lose half of it when
you die and because sekito is bloody
tough you actually have to have
really flawless run before you actually
accrue enough experience some abilities
cost five full experience bars which
means you should always be conscious of
how much experience you have and how
much experience you need because you
might want to take a trip back to a
Buddhist statue I found most enemies
also drop gold called sin in secular
which can be sucked up to your character
by holding down the square button
something I guarantee you're gonna
forget after you wipe a whole squad of
enemies try to remember because gold can
let you buy consumables it can let you
upgrade your prosthetic arm but most
importantly perhaps it also is used to
buy spirit emblems which are bought at
the Buddha statues for 10 gold upon
Buddha statues are also where you
increase your character's core strength
every mini boss drops prayer beads and
when you have four prayer beads you can
actually use them to increase your
vitality and your posture it's a really
big increase so you should kill mini
bosses in addition after you defeat a
main boss it seems that you receive a
memory of that battle confront that
memory at a Buddha statue and you'll
gain an extra attack power point which
means you do more damage and you deal
more posture damage so opie and there's
another important Buddha statue it's
sitting right next to the sculptor on
the left when you enter the temple here
you can make offerings it seems and the
Great Buddha will then stir your
thoughts allowing you to awaken in a
different location locations that
apparently existed long ago the first
offering you find is the young Lords
Bell which is acquired when you talk to
this old woman here and it will take you
back to the Hirata estates three years
past this place contains important story
events
it contains prosthetic weapons and it
also contains gourd seeds which is
something that you give to Emma and they
allow you to upgrade your healing flasks
while you're here in the errata estates
keep an eye out for treasure carp
they're these enormous pink fish that
you have to chase down like crystal
lizards and kill them before they
disappear they drop scales which
be taken to pot noble Harun Agha found
off to the right of the herati Estates
bridge this guy sells divine grass which
restores vitality a dragon's blood
droplet which cures dragon rot withered
red gourd which allows your God to heal
burn damage and a mysterious mask
fragment and a floating passage text
which unlocks a graceful combat art
throughout your journey you can also
develop latent skills our first example
of this is shinobi medicine ranked one
which players unlocked after they
defeated the chained ogre so the way you
learn such techniques it says is to be
gravely injured time and time again by
worthy opponents I think this means you
just have to kill mini-bosses but we'll
see get two injured and you'll die but
in sekito you get a couple of second
chances there's two nodes of
Resurrection this one with a snowflake
symbol can only be restored by resting
at an idol remember you have to manually
press rest now when you sit down at a
checkpoint there's another node of
Resurrection though it's got a leaf
symbol on it and this one is earned back
when you kill enemies and the circle
will fill as you kill more and more this
might lead you to believe that you have
two resurrections and you do but when
you die a black strike through will
prevent you from taking that second
resurrection for a little while from
what I can tell the black strike through
is only removed when you kill around
five regular enemies or it's removed
when you take off one boss health bar
this means you're incentivized to kill
enemies and restore both nodes of
Resurrection before you get into a boss
fight if you're having trouble
apparition type enemies are also a thing
and they can only be defeated by using a
divine confetti consumable speaking of
which the terror meter is related to
these evil enemies it's an effect that
is imparted by horrific enemies whenever
you take damage or when you don't
successfully deflect their attacks fill
this bar completely and you'll take a
huge chunk of your health off maybe even
an instant kill so if you don't have a
fear reducing item on
and the best thing to do is hide and
regain your courage if you're having
difficulty with an encounter eat some
sugar
these have different very simple combat
effects the red one are Co boosts damage
the gold gokon boosts posture the blue
Ango boosts defense and the green got
chin boosts stealth the cool thing about
these is now that sekito comes with a
pause button you're actually encouraged
to scrounge through your inventory
finding the perfect item for the perfect
situation you don't have to fumble your
quick select bar anymore which is nice
for post combat situations there are
water balloons there too I know of so
far there's a green one that boosts item
discovery and there's a gold one which
boosts gold it's probably a blue one
which boosts experience use these oh
there's a lot of stuff so thanks for
watching and if you're still not
confident watch this video where I'm
gonna go over some opie tips and tricks
instead of the fundamentals which we
just covered click the notification bell
if you want to be alerted whenever a new
video goes out and you won't miss out on
any cicchitto stuff I'll see you then